[Music]
my name it's very strange it does not
match my face
Joel Kim booster why you know Joel up
top there that seems pretty Jewish
doesn't make any sense at all Kim in the
middle that seems closer and then
booster right there at the end well
that's just a word not a name at all
what's happening there and the reason I
have this very goofy name is yes I was
adopted by a nice white Midwestern
couple in the mid 80s like many Korean
babies were Korea in the mid 80s if you
were around you probably remember it was
the only country that would fly a baby
to the US and you didn't have to go and
pick it up so it was very much the
GrubHub of babies back then it was
delivered by a very grumpy man on a bike
forgot my mom's Pepsi wouldn't go back
for it was the disaster so as you can
imagine it was a little weird growing up
in the Midwest with this face and that
family I mean I literally knew I was gay
before I knew I was Asian
[Applause]
actually cream is quite a shock when I
finally found out I'm what you know like
but it's weird to to me because we talk
so much in this country about how like
the South is the most racist part of our
country but I can tell you with full
authority that the Midwest is just as
racist as the south it just has none of
the personality you know it's all the
hatred and violence but no sweet tea you
know what's the point I'll get to the
west coast eventually don't worry yeah
it's a strange I was very difficult for
me growing up in that environment
because they don't meet a lot of like
cultural expectations of what an Asian
person should be in this country you
know like I'm terrible at math I don't
know karate my dick is huge you know
[Applause]
we constantly disappointing white people
terrible actually don't know if it's
that big or not because every time I
look at it it's pixelated so it's really
anyone yeah okay good some perverts in
the audience you guys I'm single to been
single for a while now my friends they
try to help me out they give me a lot of
advice they're always like Joel like
don't be so thirsty don't be so
desperate like play hard to get that's
the one that I hear the most play hard
to get which is very difficult for me to
do because I'm very easy to get there is
sexually gullible I've been tricked into
a lot of situations that I'm so
available that in the last calendar year
this is a hundred percent true I have
been stood up by three different men on
three different first dates yeah I know
it sucks I think like the hardest part
about that for me though it's just not
knowing how those men died you know it's
the not knowing that hurts the most
really so I was a pretty good kid
growing up which is actually like a
ridiculous premise for a joke many gay
comedians have this premise but what
does that actually mean because have you
guys ever met a six year old they're all
hella gay you know I don't know what
criteria we're using to project our
expectations of sexuality on to a child
but there's not a six-year-old in this
country crushing puss right now all
right like it's just it doesn't happen
oh but for the sake of my joke
I was pretty gay and it was never more
apparent than Christmas 1996
I wanted what every little boy in the
nation wanted for Christmas you guys
know what it is the crimp and curl pony
by the Cabbage Patch company my mom was
super cool she got it for me I opened it
up on Christmas morning I just started
crimping and curling right away my dad
less enthused he looked at my mom and he
was like Janet what the hell like why
would you get him this girls toy this is
a toy for girls and my mom looked at my
dad and was like well Ken my brother Bob
he used to get baby dolls for Christmas
and now he's a pediatrician so case
closed and my dad like rightfully looked
at my mom and was like what the hell do
you think he's gonna be a horse
hairstylist like what's the endgame here
Janet and you know I I remember my dad
saying that and I remember thinking is
that a profession
[Applause]
you